des flammes s'échappent encore du
dernier étage de cet immeuble
résidentiel il ne reste presque plus
rien au moins cette missile se sont
abattus sur cette zone il y a d'abord eu
des explosions puis des sirènes le
premier coup était loin mais nous sommes
allés tout de suite à l'abri nous étions
trois là-bas ensuite il y a une série
d'explosion je n'ai pas vraiment compris
ce qui se passait mais mon goût à sale
vive dans le nord-ouest du pays où une
colonne de fumée domine le ciel tout
comme à Kiev la capitale des carrefours
routiers des parcs publics et des sites
touristiques ont été bombardés ce sont
les premières frappes depuis plus de
trois mois des frappes précises et
ciblées selon le président zellinski
des dizaines de missiles iraniens de
type shahides sont tirés
ils veulent créer la panique et ils
veulent détruire le système énergétique
ils sont désespérés la deuxième cible
sont les civils
dans le nord-est du pays les civils ont
une nouvelle fois eu le réflexe de se
mettre à l'abri sous terre dans une
station de métro des représailles
pleinement assumées par Vladimir Poutine
dans la matinée d'aujourd'hui comme
suggéré par le ministère de la Défense
et en accord avec le plan établi par
l'état-major de la Russie une frappe
massive a été lancée avec des armes de
longue portée et de haute précision
depuis les airs la mer et la terre sur
les infrastructures de l'énergie du
commandement militaire et de
communication de l'Ukraine
l'ancien président russe s'appelle lui
au démantèlement total du pouvoir
ukrainien
et le président